контрольно-пропускні пункти України
тарусі за сир і після анексії питання
краще мало інфраструктуру це протирати
ставили з упорами правилами
тисячу можна проводити з одного боку
часто за барона на ось це день чого
порід але там їжджу за кубованим кримом
можна обидва на автомобілі
абу фішкою під локшиною 2 кілометри і вид
запинкою і для кордонного вугілля до
рід таких процедур тут їх тонни в
захопленні хотілося б що робити б у
мирні спасиби повернуть їм у скільки
більше злив та й уже крутіть а хоче
назад крутяться хочуть назад на те щоб
це ваще з приводу той крим 3 бутуз аналога
dt піднято економіку запускати
вирівнятися твоїм zuza мишка якщо про
кордоном у районі на душі вірити рівень
інтеграції крим вказувати конфлікт на те
затягнувся просто мережа spv
островом ви navi вдень і практично відрі
за не
а не видно їздить і до роду чим не може
вони торгують на кримських ринках
але вірші коли крим бог був у просто і
людям було пробач шостого етапу вірна
криму веселим і методи ми тут не хочеш
а джен адміністративному кордоні закупівля
Іван Імпе островом дібровиці ловити на
скількох кришка ммр і висока напруга
власний миша додайся в жадібному
якраз обраним членам однозначно що
українська влада регулярно за 3 травня
диверсантів та тато роджі ці теракти
стоять же чоловік і
офіційно вважається на кордоні восени
текст стабільно на пружину на даний
момент передач на
fix купу политих або каптерів вздовж
адміністративними ж
то
безплат летальні апарати та кисті зняти
розвитку
плечей о плюс при гордон ікони протирайте
активістів романського формування оскар
он і за неспокій не пройдусь їм
розмахуванням проросійських настроїв про
кремом та жителями області я вважаю що
взагалі я поважаю ще в Херсонській області
готується з датою надумаєш перевірить і
і у сідла одні настанови та вся змія
китай проти
там ще тут змі що протягнути про те
україни проти україни від складні юнони
шер інтеграцію крима гавкаємо вузли звістка
тримати хор сальський район
у рази агресії спині а і йдуть на
вимикаюсь